today I've been inspired by Hank green
who recently made a video talking about
15 of his favorite feelings here are
some of mine although I can't promise
I'll come up with 15 helping somebody
else to accomplish some kind of goal
even if it's just by offering moral
support and then watching them
accomplish the goal so good if I'm
honest I think that that feeling
actually makes me feel happier than
accomplishing my own goals although I
don't know why booting up the Legend of
Zelda Ocarina of Time it is for me
personally the best nostalgia hit I can
possibly get if I'm ever feeling sad one
of my go-to solutions is actually just
to sit and play ocarina of time until I
feel better again and it usually works
as well that's just the effect that game
has on me Huddle's just just did all of
their forms many different kinds of
cuddles and I like them I like cuddles
one of Hanks feelings was when somebody
that you really respect tells you that
they really respect you too which I very
nearly almost feel for me it's when I
hear from a third party that somebody
that I really like really likes what I
do as well because I hear it from the
person themselves just get really
awkward I don't know what to say but if
I hear it from someone else then I can
fully appreciate just how lovely that
actually is when somebody that you love
smiles at you and then you smile back
and they smile back even harder and you
smile back even harder until you kind of
get stuck in this like perpetual loop of
smiling until one of you is eventually
just like I can't smile anymore
we must couple now that's the only
solution which is usually me because I
everything comes back to cuddling for me
ultimately when you've had a hard day at
work and you get into bed it's kind of
one of the simplest pleasures in life
which is maybe why I'm feeling so
awkward mentioning it in my top 15 but
is it not just one of the best feelings
in the world I mean it's just like it's
just such bliss I love beds is that okay
can I love bed I love bed when you're in
a really bad state of mind and you're
just sort of beating yourself up about
something just feeling really stressed
or anxious and then you're able just to
take a step back from those feelings and
look at them from the outside I really
find that just like giving myself that
perspective just asking questions about
why I might be feeling that way just
gives me this great sense of calm that
is just invaluable it's just that
technique has saved my brain many a time
when you're seeing someone that you
haven't seen in a really really long
time all you're just meeting somebody
completely new and you instantly fall
into
like super comfortable conversation with
them it's that moment where you're just
like ah thank thank God for you thank
God that you are here because you are
just making my life so much more
pleasurable right now putting on a new
pair of glasses that actually have the
right prescription in them so that you
could see everything again it's so like
I'm just looking at like a damp towel
right now and been like I could see all
of the detail in the towel so beautiful
vision Thunder ratings when I've made
something that I'm really really proud
of and I share that thing with someone
and they react in exactly the way that I
was hoping they would it's just the best
kind of relief conversely when they
don't react how you're hoping they will
then it yes it can just be kind of
terrible but this is supposed to be
about happy feeling so forget that
butterflies little birds chirping those
rare little aha moments that happen over
the course of writing a story I mean on
the whole the writing process is kind of
a horrible brain breaking slog but those
few moments that you do get when you've
been suffering with a story problem for
ages and you finally figure out a good
solution and it fits everything to give
it perfectly it's just like aha but
better sitting down with my girlfriend
eating dinner watching Gilmore Girls and
then the theme song plays at it
instantly the best part of my day
I mean this does happen with pretty much
any TV show that I watch where the theme
song has had a bit of time to get stuck
in my head but right now it's Gilmore
Girls and I have no shame
team Rory should have found a better
boyfriend somewhere else because they're
all kind of terrible and those are just
some of my little feelings that I have
in my little heart do you let me know
your favorite feelings as well and I
will see you next time good bye you've
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool thank you very much
for watching if you'd like to see my
previous video that's up there and if
you'd like to see Hanks original video
that inspired this one that's down there
I've got to be honest I was kind of
nervous to make this video I don't know
what it is just guys don't normally
share their feelings so it feels a bit
awkward but now that I've done it it was
actually really lovely it really did
feel very cathartic so I strongly
recommend that you have a go at doing
all of these yourself
just be honest just be honest about your
feelings people that is the end of this
bit bye